welcome to statistics at the khan
academy and the purpose of this video is
to give you an overview of what's
included in the statistics section here
in the khan academy and really so that
you can navigate it according to what
your needs are so we start off with a
bunch of exercises that are really
around reading interpreting and
constructing different types of charts
and graphs so anything from reading
tables we also have one on creating bar
charts which is pretty fun where we're
given some data and you have to
construct the appropriate bar charts
reading line charts but if you already
feel fairly comfortable with all of this
and you don't need much practice in it i
do recommend going immediately to the
statistics intro the mean
median and mode to kind of go into the
meat of what would typically be covered
in an introductory statistic statistics
course
and as you feel and as you kind of get
the concepts that are covered in the
videos we have more and more exercises
that start to go through
those concepts so this is the exercise
on mean median mode exploring mean
median mode on and on then we talk a
little bit about box and whisker plots
we start going into variant sample
variants and we go all the way pretty
deep into kind of a introductory
inferential statistics and you see here
especially on some of the earlier topics
we have a good bit of exercises that are
sprinkled in in between the videos so
anyway hopefully that serves your needs
if you want to get a little practice
interpreting data you can start on some
of these original lectures these initial
exercises if you already feel that
that's
you know that reasonably well i
recommend you go straight to statistics
intro the mean median and mode